rollers from Central Valley your
entrepreneurs from Central Valley
entrepreneurs is my favorite job that's
like
sometimes you'll go on like dating apps
and that'll be someone's job and you're
like unemployed okay you know the record
store I own a pizzeria
you guys know that somebody's already
beaten you to that territory right maybe
it's just my version of entrepreneurs as
like an inventor to some extent you're
not that no you just have a record place
yes and you a pizza place and you guys
are like we both sell circles that
people like
this can work
not to dig in too deep but one would
think that you were just people who ran
businesses
okay then you're business owners this is
what happens when you're in San
Francisco people like I actually I've
invented the business what do you do for
work sir
unemployed you know sir I've got a
solution to that just say you're an
entrepreneur